we must look beyond ourselves with
empathy and compassion for those we know
and those we don't prince harry and
meghan markle are doing their part to
improve the world
on saturday the duke of sussex took the
stage at the vax live benefit concert
delivering a powerful speech
hi everybody
harry along with megan serve as chair
members of the global citizen campaign
who put on the event in an effort to
call on world leaders
to make sure vaccines are accessible for
all harry kicked things off by
thanking frontline workers in the
audience and the millions of others
around the world
you spent the last year battling
courageously
and selflessly to protect us all you've
served
and sacrificed put yourselves in harm's
way
and acted with bravery knowing the cost
we owe you an incredible debt of
gratitude
thank you harry then reminded the
audience that none of us should be
comfortable
while many others are still suffering
from the pandemic
because this pandemic will not end
unless we act
an unprecedented commitment to our
shared humanity
the vaccine must be distributed to
everyone
everywhere we cannot rest
or truly recover until there is fair
distribution
to every corner of the world the duke of
sussex also
encouraged everyone to seek empathy for
those who have struggled during covet
19.
in reality and especially with this
pandemic
when any suffer we all suffer
we must look beyond ourselves with
empathy
and compassion for those we know and
those we don't
we need to lift up all of humanity and
make sure
that no personal community is left
behind
this marks harry's first public
appearance since attending the funeral
of his late grandfather prince philip
in london last month before taking the
stage at the event
harry was seen backstage chatting and
taking pictures with fans
notably missing was his wife meghan
markle who was currently pregnant with
their second child
a girl in april e.t spoke with royal
expert katie nichol
about what they might name their first
daughter i absolutely think that they
will want to
include diana as perhaps one of the
names for their little girl maybe not at
her first name but
i'm sure it's um i'm sure it's very high
up on the list in terms of the second
christian name and i think that's quite
simply because it would be
for harry a wonderful way to pay tribute
to his mother
of course the cambridges gave charlotte
diana as a middle name i don't think
that precludes
harry and megan from doing exactly the
same thing i think it's very likely
to be chosen as a middle name